pour défendre et faire valoir les
vieilles brasseries du bon vieux temps
et pour évidemment limiter le dégâts que
pourrait nous faire les établissements
beaucoup plus modernes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces brasseries du bon vieux temps
sont-elles menacées un comité de défense
prend en main à leur sauvegarde et leur
prestige
c'est un comité qui a été créé justement
pour défendre et faire valoir les
vieilles brasseries du bon vieux temps
et pour évidemment limiter le dégâts que
pourrait nous faire les établissements
beaucoup plus modernes faire connaître à
la clientèle les policiers qui lui sont
offertes lui faire savoir qu'on peut
manger aussi bien et à moindre prix
qu'ailleurs voilà le but recherché
vous entendez quoi par là genre
finalement les gens vont dans cet
établissements dans un but d'économie or
ils peuvent très bien manger chez nous à
des prix voire moindres tout aussi bien
et tout en étant d'ailleurs servi en ce
moment voyez on essaye quoi qu'on en
ayant pas un besoin immense lorsqu'on
peut dire que dans l'ensemble sont des
maisons qui ont malgré tout une certaine
attirance il est quand même toujours bon
de renouveler sa clientèle ou de la
réintéresser face à ces jeunes maisons
dont vous parlez tout à l'heure
[Musique]
comme celle-ci remonte à fort loin on
fêtera je crois le sang en mer alors
quelques années d'ici or ce sont des
maisons qui ont toujours su garder
justement une certaine cote auprès du
public mais enfin il est quand même bon
malgré tout de le rappeler oui je viens
ici depuis une bonne quinzaine d'années
je préfère l'ancien modèle genre
chez Molard notre surprise plutôt que de
dire je préfère l'ancien style je suis
d'ailleurs de l'autre gros siècle j'aime
beaucoup l'ambiance et on y est très
bien
très famille
ce comité
il démarre mais c'est pas parce que la
prochaine réunion aura lieu le mois
prochain et c'est vraiment là que nous
allons prendre un départ ce comité de
défense de vieilles brasserie de mon de
Paris et vous pensez que vous avez
sur le plan coupole non je ne pense pas
qu'on en ait besoin mais on a toujours
besoin des autres n'est-ce pas dans la
vie et il faut un tout pour réaliser
quelques jours je ne peux pas nous
couper le seul rétent de plaire à toute
la clientèle de Paris c'est pas possible
les brasseries ne s'adressent pas
uniquement à une clientèle de personnes
incertaine âges nous sommes depuis
plusieurs années des jeunes nous
remarquons que les jeunes viennent dans
nos maisons et surtout ce qui nous
demandent c'est de ne pas changer ni les
cadres ni le style de la maison donc le
rock-star plaît peut-être à une certaine
clientèle mais il faut que les
brasseries subsistent comprenez c'est
très important et là-dessus c'est une
constatation les jeunes nous suivent
nous incitent à ne pas changer à rester
absolument suivre la tradition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis partisan de ces institutions de
ces partisans mais malheureusement pour
moi ça représente une autre génération
et je trouve que c'est très c'est très
sympathique de la part de ce groupement
je ne dis pas de de se révolter contre
nous nous les jeunes mais d'essayer de
sauvegarder certaines traditions de la
brasserie parce que pour moi la
brasserie représente deux images très
importantes la première c'est une table
ronde c'est un guéridon avec des
soucoupes et des soucoupes qui marquent
les consommations que le consommateur la
nouvelle génération ne boit plus
qu'est-ce qu'elle recherche la recherche
de défoulement à la recherche des
rencontres c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai fait cette établissement d'une
dimension de brasserie mais
malheureusement pas pas du tout le
l'atmosphère de l'ancienne brasserie la
deuxième image de la brasserie pour moi
était une terrasse au bord au bord d'une
grande artère parce que le spectacle du
consommateur était la rue à l'époque il
voyait certainement pas se passer des
jolies dames et et des carrosses et des
et des fiables mais malheureusement les
le bruit infernal des voitures de la rue
la corrosion de l'air empêche maintenant
de participer de participer avec cette
avec cette chose extraordinaire qui est
ce spectacle de sa mère qui est la rue
la rue était devenu une chose impossible
la compétition reste ouverte souhaitons
seulement que brasserie du bon vieux
temps et drugstore fasse toujours bon
ménage
[Musique]